Berenice Mariana Jocelyn Rosa Gabriela
Sandra seis mujeres desaparecieron el 7
de marzo en Celaya en el estado mexicano
de Guanajuato cuando se dirigían a
trabajar en un banquete los cadáveres
calcinados de cinco de ellas fueron
identificados tras ser hallados en una
fosa común confirmar el hallazgo de la
sexta víctima depende de establecer
entre los restos su perfil genético muy
pequeños
dado que quien llevó a cabo este
terrible
suceso durante las pruebas de la vida y
luego pisó desaparecer
los cuerpos incinerándolos Entonces ha
sido compleja precisamente su el poder
lograr la identificación de los restos
que tenemos sobre todo porque están
calcinados el móvil de los criminales no
ha sido establecido pero hasta el
momento hay doce detenidos supuestos
miembros de las bandas que ejercen el
control de la ciudad
estas personas se dicen pertenecer a un
grupo criminal todos ellos reitero son
oriundas de Tamaulipas una de ellas de
Honduras y dicen estar al servicio de un
grupo criminal Entonces
es una de las es lo que puede adelantar
de este caso
familiares en las víctimas se quejaron
de la falta de información por parte de
las autoridades y denunciaron que se
enteraron por los medios de que los
restos Ya habían sido identificados
Juana hermana de Sandra paredes una de
las víctimas También estuvo desaparecida
brevemente cuando fue la fiscalía a
denunciar que su familiar no había
regresado a casa se la hayas considerada
la sexta ciudad más peligrosa del mundo
por la rivalidad entre los carteles de
Jalisco y Santa Rosa por diversos
negocios ilegales